[Music]
the the oem's building these vehicles is
a nightmare he had a great relationship
with daimler and daimler could have come
in and helped him solve all of his
manufacturing problems with with
vehicles
and it would have been a walk in the
park and he would have been building
twice as many cars as he is today
and now it would have required him to
give up some of the company but who
cares so what we did is we said you know
what we don't want to do our
you know we think it's not smart to do
our own service and we don't think it's
smart to
actually un own the flight or to build
the trucks ourselves we want a partner
to help us
so we win we partnered with eveco
they're the fifth largest truck oem in
the world they have 50 years five
decades of
of heavy duty trucking experience in
cold weather arctic weather heavy duty
roads
and all over europe they are they
they're just huge
and so they came in and they said look
trevor we have one of the best trucks in
the world but
we have no technology and we said well
that's good because we have the best
powertrain technology in the world we
think
but we have no we have no expertise in
the truck chassis world
and um so we partnered up with iveko and
they
they helped us with they spent four
years and billions of dollars building a
brand new truck platform
and in europe all the trucks are the
same so a battery electric truck's
identical to a diesel truck in europe
it's they have to be because of
because of length restrictions and
everything so
we partnered up with them and now we
have the first ever zero emission truck
coming to market it's got 720 kilowatt
hours of battery
and it goes over 300 miles and so we
know battery
as good or better than anyone in the
world and we're even beating tesla to
the market with our semi truck that's
why he just recently
and why elon went out and told his team
to full focus on the semi truck because
we're beating them to the market
so on the freeway or within the cities
battery kicks
hydrogen's butt within the city a lot of
times almost every time
but as soon as you get on the freeway
that's where hydrogen that's where
hydrogen makes it so we do both of them